the Minnesota police and Peace Officers
Association also plays a role in this
investigation it represents more than
10,000 public safety officers across the
state and does have a legal defense fund
for members including the four officers
that have been linked to the killing of
George Floyd the Association works
closely with the Minneapolis Police
Union and helped facilitate our
interviews we thank them for that and we
spoke with the executive director that's
Brian Peters about the way forward so
you're paying their legal their legal
costs for all four of the officers yes
all four officers are covered under into
the legal defense fund every police
officer every citizen has the right to
due process and it just has to play out
what to you would be a fair outcome in
this particular case I know it's not up
to you I get that is there a fair
outcome I don't think there is the facts
of the case have not come out and that
will come out in a criminal trial but
it's not for me to say I think officer
shaman's he betrayed the badge and
there's no excuse for it can you talk
about the morale the mood among the
officers Minneapolis is is suffering
this is to me a systemic problem with
the entire leadership the expectations
that are put on cops these days is
enormous deal with mental health give it
to the cops drug you know drug mental
health give it to the cops
police officers have to try to put
band-aids on systemic issues and it's
overwhelming do you see this Brian as a
black-and-white issue because the black
community certainly does I never saw
black and white when I was on the street
I think it's great that you said you
don't see it as black and white but what
you know about police officers do you
think for them it is a black and white
issue that white officers are either
afraid or they're uncomfortable when
they're dealing with black people on the
streets do you think there's any truth
to that whatsoever lease officers are
are forced to again deal with societal
issues that they can't fix in 20 minutes
and we need to be looking at all of the
other systemic things that create that
divide between a white officer and a
person of color we're still pointing
fingers at this point and not doing
anything that we need to be doing
Brian Peters I thought had a very
touching point at the end of the
interview he held up thousands of
letters that have come in from police
police officers and their families
saying how much pressure they feel how
they feel unappreciated by the public of
this particular time that there are so
many police officers who are doing a
really good job and not enough focuses
paid attention to that but once again
you have to figure out a way to reform
the department we have to at least
acknowledge that there's a problem yeah
with some of the techniques that are
used people are calling it systemic
racism so it's hard to advance when we
can't even agree that there is a problem
that's the first thing you have to do
yes I think his point that was also good
that when he says that police are often
asked to do things that society itself
can't seem to fix with the mental health
issues exactly right and and and to do
it in 20 minutes yep hey Tony yeah I
mean both you make good points there I
mean the systemic racism question it's
always amazing to me when there's a
denial there because you know black
Americans are arrested charged and car
serated and killed at a disproportionate
rate and if you're not saying that
there's systemic racism that causes that
then what are you saying
we don't have an answer on that